book recommendations for when your  cheating wife finally marries that  dirtbag  joshua me and my wife are having a bit  of a rough patch  and by rough patch i mean she is  marrying  another man  things have been go things have been  looking up for me too i can do whatever  i want  i can uh cut all my hair off and uh not  go to work anymore i can invest in game  stop at exactly the wrong time  look i i can even do this cereal for  dinner let me just  this is going to be so good this is this  is the taste of freedom  i put the milk in first  i ruined it  the first book i want to recommend is  the gunslinger by stefan  king i wonder when my kids are going to  start  calling joshua dad